oh and Colt no more news Oh
Colt I have a hard time saying I worried
I just realized pool cool Colt oh cool
Paul colt cool okay
submitted by Korean boo I don't remember
those words the former wife of a jailed
polygamist sect leader wants to turn his
mansion into a tourist attraction he
wasn't present but he has he's in prison
now
oh the former wife of this jailed
polygamist sect leader wants to turn his
mansion into a tourist attraction so you
could see all the cult [ __ ] that was
going on I've got the whole tourist
attraction part I'm like I don't get it
but if the cult is big enough for this
guy to buy a mansion it's probably
widely known yeah it's actually it spans
across multiple states
herbalife Oh choice so long Warren jet
61 years old he was a spiritual head of
a breakaway sect called Fundamentalist
Church of Jesus Christ of latter-day
saints from the mainstream Mormon
religion God accepted it
did she just placed a lot of issues so
they're specialized Mormon sect yeah
pretty much especially they're referred
to as SLDS for short film films
that's the Fundamentalist Church of
Jesus Christ latter-day saints correct
yeah mr. long okay a lot of those words
were not accounted for in that acronym
yeah all right so he had spent months on
the run from authorities so he was
finally arrested during a traffic stop
back in August of 2006 so the reason why
he was arrested was because he was
consists of all he was condemned for
promoting marriage between young
and old man's clothes yeah and probably
had some u9y
whoa that's it Genghis Khan had way more
food back in 2011 Warren was convicted
of sexually assaulting his bride that
were as young as 12 years old oh so he
is he has been sentenced to life in
prison plus 20 years on top of life
competing so now the wife is like you
want to see where a pedophilia took
place yeah see the tourist attraction
part I don't understand but let me
explain a wild she wants to buy this
match okay looks justify it yeah
okay so the mansion is estimated at
about 1.2 million dollars where what
stages so it's in Utah but it's on the
border between Utah and Arizona by a
huge-ass how steady yeah 1.2 million
dollars goes a long way in Utah and
everywhere about California yeah yeah so
his worshippers they like literally
believe that he is a prophet who
channels in the Word of God and so they
believe every word he says and the fact
that he's now in prison like you know
they're really upset about it there's a
lot of people that still believe that
he's still running the church from
inside the prison like the Mexican Mafia
nah [ __ ] down any mafia is debacle
adding you to khalaby yes please yeah so
the property that belonged to the SEC
they were held in a trust I was
established back in nineteen in the
1940s below members of that sex could
benefit from its shared assets but the
state of Utah seized this trust back in
2005 and now they're selling back its
assets to the flood spelled más sobre el
deck herbs 31 years old
she's his former wife is China buy the
property
she was his succeed bisque why isn't she
saying that she was forced into a
marriage when she was 18 years old but
luckily she never consummated marriage
oh lucky her which means she never had
sex for those who don't know Timmy yeah
so she ended up escaping so five years
ago and the way she escaped was by
pounding open the window of the trailer
that she said she was confined to she
ended up running to a neighbor for help
because like they were transporting her
through all these different homes there
are all these different states because
she don't want to be there for scherzer
aftere will so this dude just sounds
like 79 trailers each one with the wife
inside no I like this property why would
you want 79 headaches that's crazy to me
I think you see 79 [ __ ] but I think
at that point though you get to have
them team up on each other so for
example if you're fighting one you can
talk to the other practical jumpers to
fight together
so he's manipulative it's just way
easier I think if you have like two or
three it's bad we kept over 50 it's
really good mmm and so now Brielle she's
saying that she wants him by this
property and she hopes to turn this
mansion into a home for ex members of
the church and she also wants to make it
a tourist attraction over that part I
still I don't understand apart but she's
also saying are a center for public
events and tours and eventually she
wants to install a restaurant and a gift
shop in this property oh I don't know
like if I would like help capture or
captive organs I will in this place I
would not want to go back there exactly
okay okay she trying to restart this
election I will show you how to run a
cult we go get some restaurant you know
she seemed like she really want to turn
that place that was so negative and like
she had a lot of trauma in her life she
also turn it to something positive and
to help other members because advocates
for like people that have been in pulse
they say that they need way more safe
houses because if there's no safe houses
and these people that escape these Colts
they'll probably be lured back in by
elders that one want them to come back
in if they don't have anywhere safe to
go to get away from this cult so that's
what she wants to create this place to
be it is fascinated it almost seems like
it's a gang
but everyone's I have ever seen that's a
part of a cult I feel like I could just
kill them so I don't know if I would
ever be able to be if I was going to
call in if I want to leave I'll just
leave and I think if someone want to
learn me back you know like i'ma kill
you stop talk if you don't stop talking
to me that's why you're not a target I
want to be a halt experience this is
Warren just awesome imprison he is
creepy yeah that's him it's funny that
he's creepy when he really just looks
like a regular white man but he
definitely looks creepy yeah thank you
think about how they know a lot of
regular white men just was very creepy
you know I think is so creepy about that
last week that you showed us before that
when his lips and his skin face with the
same color oh that's dangerous sign of a
record yeah you all you also know his
nipples and his standards the same
constant of course there's just one
flesh so right through maybe he doesn't
have NASA started all of this I wonder
how hard it is to start a cult because I
feel like there's a lot of people that
just do it I don't wanna be like a
system on how to do it
no it's like a holiday isn't it is there
called school I don't think there is but
it's the same the same way pins get
prostitutes hmm I think I can do that
better than I could be a cult like how
do you convince someone that you're at
the coming of Jesus and then you're like
this person where if I'm in jail like
you still are worshiping me and you want
to break me up I mean you don't always
have to be part of Jesus if you can
convince them that Jesus is not the way
I know the railway I think that's a lot
easier but that's also hard for this is
a die for you be able to die for you
I mean you're desperate enough when
you're lost in bed time in your life
have you watched holy hell on Netflix
there's a cult leader she was able to
bone straight dudes I don't think I
would ever be able to convince another
straight dude - let me bomb them mmm I
don't have that kind just gotta find the
right dude I think you can I feel like I
was like a bet that he had against
another cult leader as I do you know
what I did to be you guys they gave me
all their money
that's funny cuz I [ __ ] these dudes me
ask
like get that photo you get it bro like
you want to see smell my dick smell like
it smell like poop oh wow that's too far
okay yeah I do bed hey he's the rapist
let's go focus on him music photos in
the property that's Creole pray and obey
pray and obey that's what it says yeah
yeah [ __ ] that he's good yeah and so
it's like a campus damn this place is
huge not the nice passing there is a
video like a two-minute three-minute
video of like to score the house - like
sped up and I I was thinking about
playing it for you guys I got busy
watching it so because I holy crap how
many rooms were there Dido there's 41
bedroom oh boy I'm here curating a lot
of money yeah the gym yeah with only
like three machines in this whole place
what the [ __ ] the gym is that what's
mainly all empty so I don't know if they
got emptied out once you went to jail
I'll do it has a same ugly Church carpet
color that every single [ __ ] Church I
was about to say very few pieces of
furniture around the house I could
already smell with it like I don't know
it smell like
cult life seems pretty good though
saying that this is a room where they
would all kneel and pray every hour on
the hour
what is she reenact it looks like the
power every hour she go there and pray
that sucks your movies are interrupted
you get a logical movie yeah now that
place is huge there's um there's even
two commercial sized kitchen oh [ __ ] I
think I want to do photos you could see
my son and donging that the industrial
kind of thing is I'm so interesting then
like I know for a fact I couldn't ever
get into a cult because even like
growing up in a church I'm very
particular about the the churches that I
choose to go because some of them are a
little bit cold you know what I mean
like for example this is a funny thing
but long story short I basically went
into this thing just like a prayer house
thing and I thought would be how cool
the chill we just gonna pray together
have a good time it Korean dude came up
to me he goes excuse me can I pray for
you and I'm like yeah man clinically man
cool so you come to me goes
look like praying and talking to one of
those right it starts like spraying it
comes spinning in my face now just the
whole time I like try to break his grass
he had to be like a buck ten maybe
that's how much you waiting I couldn't
break free so I was like oh God big need
will do you know yeah I got traumatized
after that I'm not coming back to the
[ __ ] again yeah I've been to one of
those and then uh for other people
surrounding me and they were all crying
and I'm like holy [ __ ] this is crazy and
I don't know any of these guys yeah and
my friend that brought me he was just
like you have to like what if you want
to do four or five strangers is coming
up to me when he can't play for you
might do a nice Church they start crying
around me yeah it was a little little
odd and mind you like I grew up at a
church I wanted to be a youth minister
my father the pastor so that threw me
off if you have been like growing up in
that environment I'm like this is not
normal you have made this a lot I think
it's two ways to get into a cult your
family's involved and you have no choice
because you're a kid or you have a
terrible family and you're just looking
for accepted somewhere in the only way
you got to find some weak-ass
[ __ ] just like a game yeah like
that is angel hexxus angel has angels
and that's enough
look at look at him is it a prostitute
we get love it oh I heard of that I got
a mean of those they were popular they
almost had a reality show and they
really played the system and people
thought they weren't [ __ ] prophet
holy [ __ ] has his angels are such
fascinating one dude had a stable of
women he lost most of them but Wow well
Jay can use phantoms I hope you guys
liked that video once again remember if
you want to be involved just submit some
article them I'll suck your dick now but
seriously though there's more videos up
there
[Music]